it's 18 years since 9/11 President Trump
dumps his national security advisor john
bolton in republicans prevail in a North
Carolina congressional bellwether
election i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show well today does mark the
18th anniversary it's always weird to
call it an anniversary of 9/11 there are
a lot of people I know who are listening
to the show who don't remember 9/11 who
are too young to remember 9/11 which is
an amazing thing because for people who
were there it was a seminal moment much
like I'm sure the assassination of JFK
was for our parents and our grandparents
9/11 was an earth shifting moment I
remember precisely where I was when 9/11
happened we're dropping my sisters off
at school my father and I and people
rushed out into the parking lot to tell
us that the planes had hit the World
Trade Center towers it was a moment of
clarification and crystallization it was
a reminder that the world is an
incredibly dangerous place filled with
evil and foes who hate the United States
of America and it was a reminder that
America was still capable of coming
together in times when America was under
attack because the fact is that is
divided as America was at the time and I
think America is more divided now and it
was in 2001 the fact is that we are
still able to recognize the common
humanity and other Americans realized
that we shared the vast majority of the
same values realized that we were all on
the same page on an essential key level
and we got together and we recognized
that we had to go and fight the people
who had murdered 3,000 Americans who had
taken down the World Trade Centers who
had attacked the Pentagon it was a
shocking and horrifying day obviously I
still get a little bit nauseous thinking
about and I'm sure everyone who
remembers it does mean I'm not unique in
that capacity in any way shape or form
we all remember the sacrifice of the
firefighters and then the police
officers were rushing into the towers as
people were running out trying to save
people we all remember the firefighters
were there for cleanup many of whom have
gotten disease since because of all the
all of the asbestos and soot and dust in
the air we all remember the soldiers who
stood up and volunteered people who were
far braver than I was who stood up and
and said I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
fight the bad guys over there so they
never come over here and it's
remember those things because how you
view 911 as a natural outgrowth of an
isolationist foreign policy or as an
aberration in American history as you
something weird that happened at one
time shapes how we see foreign policy in
the United States today and how you
reacted to 9/11 and how will you react
now to remembering 9/11 is indicative of
where the future of American foreign
policy lies because it seems to me that
in the United States right now there is
this long slide back into the post Cold
War pre 9/11 mentality on foreign policy
which is that the United States should
retreat from the world the United States
has no place in the world that a a
stronger United States is more likely to
draw the attention of bad guys all over
the world if we sort of left the world
alone in the world would leave us alone
and 9/11 was a reminder that that wasn't
true because the fact is that the the
Clinton administration had been
extraordinarily non forthcoming in terms
of intervention ISM in fact the only
real interventionist acts they took were
on humanitarian levels right they did
that in Yugoslavia they did that in
Somalia they did that a little bit in
Sudan but the the Clinton administration
was certainly not a an aggressive
hawkish administration Bill Clinton
rapidly cut the military such that the
military was simply not ready to do a
two-front war by the time 2003 came
around and as a result of the United
States abdicating its Duty around the
world in the aftermath of the Cold War
with the assumption that the vacuum
would would not be filled by bad guys
the vacuum was indeed filled by bad guys
and we saw a spate of terror attacks
leading up to 9/11 that should have been
indicative that something like 9/11 was
going to happen we saw the 1993 World
Trade Center bombings we saw the
bombings of the Khobar towers in Saudi
Arabia in 1996 we saw the bombings of
American embassies in Tanzania and Kenya
in 1998 1999 we saw the bombing of the
USS Cole in 2000 and then of course we
saw the massive World Trade Center
attacks and that was the the final straw
that woke America from its reverie and a
second done remind you exactly what that
was like what President George W Bush
had to say at the time a time when
America was unified and and there was a
realization this brutal realization that
the world's problems would come here if
we were not actively fighting them off
away from our own doorstep we'll get to
that in just one second first got to
talk about something that is always a
little bit awkward to talk about that is
the
of sex within marriage so obviously sex
is a pretty important thing and one of
the things that you want to make sure of
is that if you've got a medical problem
you get it taken care of
even though 52 percent of dudes over the
age of 40 and 26 percent under 40
experience erectile dysfunction
studies show that 70 percent of men who
experience Headey don't get treated for
it and that's what our friends at Roman
come in thankfully Roman has created an
easy way to get checked out by a doctor
get treated for IDI online with Roman
you can get medical care for eg if
appropriate from the comfort and privacy
of your own home you can handle
everything online in a convenient
discreet manner getting started is
simple you just go to get Roman comm
/ban and you complete an online visit if
your doctor decides that treatment would
be appropriate they can prescribe
genuine medication that can be delivered
in discreet packaging directly to your
door with free two-day shipping dudes
you should go talk to a doctor you got a
medical problem that's not something to
be embarrassed about that's something to
get solved just go to get Roman comm
slash spending at a free online visit
and free two-day shipping that's get
Roman comm slash been for that free
visit to get started get Roman comm
slash men again get Roman comm slash man
ok so on 9/11 there was also a key
reminder that we also seem to have
forgotten in the United States and that
there that that reminder is that for all
the critiques we have of the United
States the people who wish to destroy
the United States if America stays true
to our own values and true to ourselves
those people are enemies of the world
and enemies of freedom hey there's a
there's a strong and I think morally
correct attempt in the United States
toward constant self correction we're
constantly introspective and we should
be we should be looking at all the
things we can do to alleviate sins of
the past and to correct problems of the
present we should do all of that but
America is a uniquely good place America
is a place of uniquely good ideals and
yes we have sinned in the past and yes
we are attempting to self-correct but
the story of America is a country that
has done an insane amount of good on the
world stage
a country that has freed billions of
people not only from tyranny but also
from poverty the United States is a
beacon of hope to the rest of the world
and when we act as we should act and our
enemies are the worst people on planet
earth and for all the talk today about
how terrible the United States is bata
o'rourke out there on the campaign trail
talking about how America is a bastion
of racism and violence the idea that
America is a dark sinister place
they get sometimes from both sides it's
just not true and it wasn't true in 9/11
either and the people who attacked us on
9/11 saw America and particularly saw
our world view a world view of
liberalism and worldview that suggested
that freedoms allow the freedom to sin a
worldview that recognized that the power
of the people still the majority should
not be able to overrule the individual
rights we all hold against government
right that world view came under attack
and we all remember this I mean for a
brief period in time all the Lakers
flags went down in Los Angeles and
American flags hung out every window
people realized that wait a second maybe
we've forgotten what America was all
about maybe in our desire for petty
politics we've forgotten what America
was all about and it took an act of evil
it took a tragedy to remind us of all of
that and honestly I prefer the term act
of evil to tragedy cuz the tragedy is
something that is sort of unavoidable
and in Greek tragedy it's it's the the
main characters fatal flaw that leads to
his downfall but that's not what
happened on 9/11 what happened on 9/11
is that the United States got tired the
United States got lazy in terms of
foreign policy and we forgot what we
were all about and then in shattering
fashion we were reminded of that and the
United States had to unify once again
and the sleeping giant was awakened
president george w bush run september
21st 2001 he went before a joint session
of congress and he demanded that the
taliban which was the evil terror group
in charge of afghanistan surrender al
qaeda because al qaeda was using
afghanistan as a home base and here's
what President George W Bush had to say
about it the leadership of al Qaeda has
great influence in Afghanistan and
supports the Taliban regime in
controlling most of that country the
United States respects the people of
Afghanistan after all we are currently
its largest source of humanitarian aid
but we condemn the Taliban regime and
tonight the United States of America
makes the following demands on the
Taliban deliver to United States
authorities all the leaders of al Qaeda
who hide in your land okay in the United
States was unified around that message
now later obviously this would all turn
very political
and people would suggest that the Bush
administration botched the invasion of
Afghanistan and then they would suggest
that the war in Iraq was completely
fruitless and pointless and this all
shattered on the on the shoals of war in
foreign places but the fact is in the
immediate aftermath of 9/11 there was a
tremendous unity in the country on the
basis of we cannot sit around and hope
that the rest of the world will leave us
alone
president Trump spelled out the changes
in American foreign policy President
Bush did he spelled out the changes in
American foreign policy and he talked
about what an American response would
look like he said it would involve more
than simple case by case retaliation and
isolated strikes our response involves
far more than instant retaliation and
isolated strikes Americans should not
expect one battle but a lengthy campaign
unlike any other we have ever seen and
we will pursue nations that provide aid
or safe haven to terrorism every nation
in every region now has a decision to
make either you are with us or you are
with the terrorists and that line
obviously became the sort of rallying
cry for the left oh look at that buying
their view of the universe but the
reality is that if you were not with the
United States in its war on Islamic
radical terrorism then you were on the
other side there is no there is no sort
of neutrality in that particular battle
George W Bush was right about that so it
seems that we have now forgotten what
exactly happened on 9/11 what that
experience was like what that experience
meant in terms of foreign policy I think
we've forgotten it on the left I think
that many people have forgotten it on
the right because it has been nearly 20
years since that happened people are
starting to view 9/11 as this historic
aberration as opposed to as I mentioned
an outgrowth of an isolationist and and
retreat based foreign policy we'll talk
about that in just one second first
let's talk about hiring at your company
so hye-rin can be a slow process CAF al
Torrez CEO o Dillon Miska wits needed to
hire a director of coffee for his
organic coffee company that he was
actually having trouble finding
qualified applicants so he switched on
over to zip recruiter zip recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them for you it's technology
identifies people with the right
experience them invites and invites them
to apply to your job so
get qualified candidates fast Dylan
posted his job on sip recruiter said he
was impressed by how quickly he had
great candidates apply he also use zip
recruiters candidate rating feature to
filter applicants so he could then focus
on the most relevant applicants and
that's how Dylan found his new director
of coffee in just a few days with
results like that it's no wonder that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter to get a quality candidate
within the very first day let's say for
example that you have a director of your
show I'd say his name is director Mike
and he just sort of weirdly laughs at
things and nobody knows quite why he
sort of sort of rants in the background
and and things get awkward and you think
to yourself well you know is there
anyone better available than director
Mike so you head on over to zip
recruiter and you check it out well four
out of five people who are looking for
our placement for director Mike might
find them add zip recruiter com I'm not
speaking about anybody specifically here
guys see why zip recruiter is effective
for businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free and our web address
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire that
is zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly WI re
zip recruiter comm slash daily wear zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire and I'm not just gonna throw Pablo
under the bus and suggest that he's the
one who told me to talk about director
Mike there but that's kind of what
happened in any case in any case when we
talk about 911 and forgetting the
lessons of 9/11 a couple of pieces of
evidence that people on the Left have
forgotten about 9/11 and then some
evidence that people on the right may be
moving away from a world view that we
remembered on 9/11 that was kind of
important in the post 9/11 world because
let's be real about this the fact is
that the United States has actions in
the aftermath of 9/11 did make America
safer they did make America safer you
know we can talk as much as we want
about how 9/11 was an aberration as a
uniquely spectacular attempt to commit
terrorism in the United States but the
fact is that I remember in the aftermath
of 9/11 there was serious fear of a
follow-on attack that fear remained for
years there was serious fear that
al-qaeda would be able to pull off
another mass casualty attack in the
United States and it took actually until
the rise of Isis for us to see similar
mass casualty attacks in the West and
that was a full decade after 9/11 and
that was again because of the United
States and its allies started to
retrench from the world they started to
move away from engagement with the world
first the evidence on the
so today the New York Times originally
tweeted about 9/11 this was their
original tweet 18 years have passed
since airplanes took aim and brought
down the World Trade Center today
families will once again gather and
grieve at the site where more than 2,000
people died really was it airplanes that
took aim and brought down the World
Trade Center I do remember that we were
launched a 20 year war on airplanes in
the aftermath of that if you were you're
either with the airplanes or you were
against the airplanes that was that was
the the basic tenor of that the New York
Times obviously then had to delete this
they said we deleted an earlier tweet to
this story and have edited for clarity
the story has also been updated the
stories lead by the way repeated exactly
the same line the stories lead also
suggested that airplanes had taken had
taken aim hey for the same reason the
media refused and still refused to show
the actual pictures of what happened on
9/11 and refused to talk about the
actual perpetrators of 9/11 and refused
to show the pictures of people leaping
from the tops of flaming buildings to
their death because they don't want to
remind America what 9/11 actually was
for the same reason the New York Times
was tweeting out about how airplanes
took game and it's not just that tweet
okay the New York Times editorial page
today online I don't receive their print
newspaper so I'm just gonna give you
their editorial page today online it is
the 18th anniversary of 9/11 you would
expect and that this might prompt some
reflection on 9/11 hey there are 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11
editorials on the website of the New
York Times as we record this right as
I'm as I'm speaking these words one of
them is about 9/11 the one about 9/11 is
titled the world 9/11 took from us it's
by a person named Omer Aziz and it's
talking about Islamophobia so eighteen
years after 9/11 we are still doing the
routine that the media did in the
aftermath of 9/11 which was that the
biggest problem facing the United States
was not evil Islamic radical terrorists
attempting to murder Westerners now the
biggest problem in the United States was
suposed brutal Islamophobia springing
from the American people in other words
the radical left knee-jerk belief that
the United States is responsible for
everything that happens to the United
States that the United States is skirt
was too short led a lot of people on the
Left who immediately respond by
suggesting that Americans were these
vicious racists who were going to
attempt to target Muslims across the
United States that wave of anti-muslim
violence never material
okay bye hate crime statistics Jews were
targeted every single year
far more than Muslims were in the United
States on a per capita basis and yet
that media narrative remained for years
that the that the real problem was that
America after 9/11 became Islamophobic
that that was the big that was the big
issue and you see this today in the
left's continued crusade to paint
America as a uniquely terrible place
when 9/11 really reminds us that you
know when you look at America in
relation to the rest of the world this
place is pretty effing fantastic and our
ideals are pretty spectacular the unity
that surrounded 9/11 lasted for about
five minutes and certainly by now on the
Left we have forgotten that unity and
we've gone back to America is
responsible for all the sins against her
and if only we would be more
conciliatory and we'd be more
multicultural if only we'd be nicer to
the immigrants then everything would be
fine now that is not an argument about
illegal immigration that's not an
argument bout legal immigration hey
that's not I'm not making an argument on
that basis I'm saying that for the left
the radical left all of America's sins
in the words of Jeremiah Wright came
home to roost on 9/11 that was a
perspective on the left it remains a
predominant perspective on the radical
left in the United States it is wrong it
is dangerous and it is morally obtuse
and then on the right we seem to have
forgotten that we have intractable foes
in the world and that they do fill the
vacuum left by the United States that
the world is not simply a place of
status quo that if the United States
moves out of particular areas America's
enemies move in and that does have an
impact and that impact may not be felt
for some years but we do have to make
difficult decisions on foreign policy
and some of those decisions are our
decisions like should we have a more
intrusive invasive hawkish foreign
policy to prevent the death of civilians
at home or should we accept the fact
that if we are more isolated from the
rest of the world in terms of foreign
policy if we leave areas to fester for
years at a time without any sort of
intervention without any sort of
American influence in those areas that
every so often we're going to take a
mass casualty attack in the United
States that Maykel 3,000 Americans
because to pretend that you can have
your cake and eat a - when it comes to
foreign policy is an immature view of
foreign policy this immature view of
foreign policy came to a head over the
last week and a half on a
the Trump administration and President
Trump himself were specifically
considering whether to have that same
Taliban the Taliban the george w bush
talked about in 2001 that had that
fostered al qaeda
the same taliban that continues to
reject the legitimate government of
afghanistan and foster terrorism
throughout Afghanistan whether that same
Taliban should be welcomed to Camp David
and the United States should cut a peace
deal with a bunch of people who
acknowledge openly that they wish to
murder Americans and hate everything the
United States stands for and you can see
this gap opening up on the right between
sort of Bush era foreign policy and the
Trump era foreign policy and I was
fearful that this was going to open up
more in 2016 when President Trump was
elected mainly because the bush and the
Bush administration made mistakes on
foreign policy right knowing now what
they knew then would they've invaded
Iraq I highly doubt it knowing now what
they knew then would they have surged
troops in Afghanistan sooner probably
knowing now what we knew then would they
have focused on building up the military
and fighting on one front war instead of
a two front war I'm sure they would have
would they have surged sooner in Iraq
even if they had gone in absolutely but
the overall foreign policy view of the
above the Bush administration was if we
do nothing we're gonna get another 9/11
and we're gonna get a lot more terrorism
and we're going to see our enemies
thrive and so we have to do more right
the Clinton era foreign policy was a
mistake in the aftermath of the of the
Bush foreign policy we got the Obama
Trump foreign policy and Trump was there
was a question an open question in 2016
as to whether Trump was going to be more
interventionist sort of like Bush or was
he going to be more Obama esque seeking
to bring America's troops home from
these far-flung places across the world
and assume that everything would sort of
be fine hey that was Obama's approach to
foreign policy in which he slashed the
military now Trump has a knee-jerk like
for the military that Obama simply
didn't have Obama had a knee-jerk
dislike for the strength of the United
States military which is why when it
came to for example sequestration he
insisted that half of the cuts come from
the military Trump innately likes the
American military loves the American
military in a way that Barack Obama
didn't and so he's built up the American
military but the question was going to
be how he deployed that military and how
he approached diplomacy versus military
versus threats versus sanctions and for
a while there it seemed that the Trump
administration was going to be more Bush
like in its general approach than Obama
like in its general approach that may be
changing that Taliban attempted meeting
was a horrible horrible idea virtually
every level in a second I'll talk a
little bit more about all of that first
let's talk about the fact that if you
work out at all if you're just seeking
to be healthy then you need to be
hydrated if you hate being dehydrated
but sugary sports drinks are not the
solution for you you need something
called liquid IV it is the fastest most
efficient way to stay hydrated it
hydrates you faster and more efficiently
than water alone and gives you the added
bonus of vitamins C b3 b5 b6 and b12
liquid IV is the fastest growing
wellness brand on the market you can
find them everywhere even at Costco all
liquid IV products utilize cellular
transport technology it's a specific
ratio of glucose sodium and potassium
when mixed with 16 ounces of water it
helps your body absorb more of the water
and nutrients you drink directly into
your bloodstream liquid IV fuels tough
workouts it helps prevent muscle fatigue
and promotes healthy post-workout
recovery so I've been urging and I've
been urging you Andrew Clavin to take it
so he remains alive I've been urging
Michael knows not to take it for
precisely the opposite reason
unfortunately both of them are taking in
both of them love it both of them say
that liquid IV really helps them out and
it makes them feel better they've been
telling me really raving about it it's
not kosher so I haven't tried it but
everybody who doesn't keep kosher
absolutely should right Andrew Clavin
and Michel moles absolutely attest that
the thing is fantastic right now my
listeners get 25 percent off at liquid
IV com when you use my code been a
checkout that is 25% off anything you
order on liquid IVs website go to liquid
IV comm and for my promo code been to
get your savings and start getting
better hydration that's liquid IV com
promo code Ben if you wish to be
hydrated and be healthier check it out
liquid IV com promo code Ben everybody
but Noel's should take it liquid IV com
promo code Ben don't wait start properly
hydrating today okay so as I say there's
this open question about the Trump
administration's foreign policy and so
far it seemed as though the Trump
administration foreign policy had been
more along sort of bushy in lines
although without the the sort of
wilsonian aggressive instincts of the
bush foreign policy so
other words the United States had to be
involved in the world but sometimes it
would just be a long-term holding
pattern it wasn't going to be the
transformation of Afghanistan into a
thriving democracy or the transformation
of Iraq into a thriving democracy it was
it was bushy an aggressive intervention
ISM with a real politic twinge and that
was actually pretty good that's pretty
good and then over the last week we've
got all this talk about the Taliban and
you could see the gaps beginning to
emerge on the right over the legacy of
9/11 so Condoleezza Rice came out
yesterday she's on CBS this morning and
she said listen this is ridiculous we
should not be negotiating with the
Taliban well I'm relieved you had we
walked away from these talks I always
wondered if it was really possible to
get a solution with a Taliban that is
not really committed to peace and there
was some bad telltale signs there's an
Afghan government that has been there
now as our ally for a decade and a half
and the Taliban says they don't
recognize them they won't talk to them
that's a bad sign okay and Condoleezza
Rice points out correctly that if the
United States withdraws from Afghanistan
it collapses back in the chaos again
with the Taliban taking over in Europe
for forty five years until Germany could
unify between 1945 and 1990 we're still
there we keep the peace on the Korean
Peninsula since 1953 and I know that
Americans are tired of some of the
responsibilities but frankly there's
nobody but the United States of America
that can do these things and so I don't
know what the right numbers are but I
hope that the president and his his
aides are asking our military what can
we do to leave enough of a presence
there to stabilize the situation now as
I say this is the conflict that is
breaking out into the open
and it seems to have broken out
specifically over this Taliban thing and
the conflict I'm talking about ends with
the firing of John bolts in the National
Security Adviser so apparently Bolton's
position with the Taliban was exactly
kind of Lisa Rice's position with the
Taliban which would be the bush position
with the Taliban frankly it can't
negotiate with terrorists and if we have
to leave a footprint in Afghanistan
indefinitely we will leave a footprint
in Afghanistan indefinitely and then
there was the other side of the equation
which was sort of Trump's instinct which
is get out now as fast as humanly
possible and if they hit us then maybe
we have to hit them again but we got to
get out as
humanly possible that side of the
equation is backed by people more like
Tucker Carlson and Rand Paul and that
came to a head with the firing of
Bolton's so according to Karen's young
JA Stasi and John Hudson over at the
Washington Post over a turbulent 17
months President Trump and national
security adviser John Bolton had
disagreed on a variety of issues from
North Korea to Venezuela to Iran but
Trump finally decided to remove his top
security aide on Tuesday after a heated
discussion in the Oval Office following
accusations by other officials in the
administration that Bolton had leaked to
the news media tried to drag others into
his battles with Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo over Afghanistan and promoted his
own views rather than those of the
president according to people familiar
with the matter Trump called on Bolton
to meet with him on Monday afternoon as
he prepared to leave for a campaign
rally that night in North Carolina
Bolton was seen by some in the
administration as the source of a media
report that vice president Pence and he
were allies in opposing a peace deal
with the Taliban negotiated by Pompeo
State Department just before the meeting
Trump had tweeted that it was fake news
designed to create the look of turmoil
in the White House of which there is
none and then of course he fired Bolton
Bolton denied the charge said I didn't
leak that to the media that there was
this big division but the Afghanistan
issue according to the Washington Post
turned out to be a tipping point among
the accumulated grievances that had been
building for months the president was
annoyed that Bolton would regularly call
on members of Congress to try to get
them to push Bolton preferred policies
on Trump according to a senior official
who like others spoke on the condition
of anonymity to discuss internal
deliberations many on Bolton's
hand-picked staff were seen as
unnecessarily confrontational with other
parts of the national security
bureaucracy now let's be real about this
the way that policy is conducted in the
Trump administration is via television
and outside influences that is the way
it is conducted okay it is not what
happens in the room so it used to be
that foreign policy was conducted in the
room basically you'd have all of your
foreign policy players they'd sit around
the table they'd bring in briefing
experts and then decisions would be made
that is not how President Trump makes
policy he makes policy by watching TV
he listens to commentary he takes in the
commentary and then he produces a
decision or he gets a call from somebody
outside and then he considers that and
then he makes decisions okay we have
seen this repeatedly on everything from
domestic to foreign policy he'll take a
call from Tucker Carlson or Sean Hannity
and then he will make decisions on the
basis of his opinion about those calls
he'll watch something on Fox News and
this will shape his thinking on how a
particular issue takes place
now it's not my preferred methodology
but people inside the administration
know this ok everyone inside the
administration knows this whether or not
they are saying so everybody sort of
acknowledges that this is how Trump's
administration works if you know anybody
in the White House you know this is true
and I know nearly everybody in the White
House okay so this is just a fact of
life
so this complaint about Bolton that he
was going to outside can Congress people
having them call everybody in the White
House does that that is nothing new that
is nothing new what really happened here
is that Trump got egg on his face over
this whole Taliban ridiculous appeal and
he's gonna bring the worst people on
earth literally some of the worst people
on earth to Camp David and then he was
going to have some sort of peace
agreement with them in which they would
promise something and then give up
nothing and then we were going to
withdraw American troops on that basis
and never reinsert them because once he
withdraw them
Trump is not going to reinsert those
troops okay it was a bad idea from the
outset Bolton the post at Bolton was
pretty loud about opposing it until
Bolton's out that's pretty much what
seems to have happened here Trump had
been inundated with complaints according
to officials pence in acting White House
chief of staff Mick Mick Mulvaney who
are awaiting Trump's arrival Monday
afternoon in Fayetteville found bolting
Lee increased Bolton increasingly
abrasive and self-promoting which is to
say the best way to get someone fired in
the Trump administration is to go to
trump and say that guy's stealing your
limelight he's on TV he's undermining
you it's always to appeal to Trump's ego
Secretary of State Pompeo and Treasury
secretary Steve minuchin had told Trump
that his national security adviser was
not helping him officials said Bolton
had even refused in recent weeks to go
on television and defend the president's
policies on Afghanistan and Russia
Bolton the president felt wasn't loyal
he wasn't on the team of course it
always comes down to that for president
Trump after Trump made his views known
Bolton offered to resign according to
Bolton Trump insisted that they would
discuss it the next day it was the last
time he saw the president he had the
meeting thought about it for a few hours
especially since the president wasn't
exactly begging him to stay on and he'd
had enough said a person familiar with
Bolton's thinking on Tuesday morning
Bolton hands at a two-sentence letter to
an aide for delivery to trump and left
the building I hereby resign effective
immediately just before noon from stole
his thunder announcing in a turf sweet
that he had fired his third national
security in a row that be after Mike
Flynn and HR at mcmaster he said I
disagreed strongly with many of his
suggestions as did others in the
administration I will be naming a new
national security adviser
next week and there's this whole debate
that broke out over whether Bolton had
resigned or whether Bolton was fired now
does this necessarily mean that Trump is
shifting radically to the isolationist
caucus when it comes to foreign policy
no it doesn't but it certainly provides
an opening to a lot of the members of
that caucus who seek to minimize
America's presence on the world stage
now again I'm not saying that's coming
from a bad place for a lot of these
folks I'm not saying that Tucker who
tends to be on the side or Rand Paul who
tends to be on this side I'm not saying
this is coming from a place that the
American Left is coming from where they
say that America's presence on the world
stage provokes attacks against the
United States and America is a force for
nefarious ends in the world I'm not
saying any of that I think that Tucker's
basic perspective is that the United
States should not be expending resources
abroad that could be better spent at
home and this is Rand Paul's perspective
too of a more tension with maybe a Ron
Paul sentiment and Tuckers perspective
is if we bring those folks home from
distant lands we can build up the United
States if somebody hits us we hit the
back and that's pretty much how this
works now you don't need an
interventionist foreign policy and
that's a good faith argument I would
suggest that the aftermath of 9/11 that
argument basically fell apart but we are
now 20 years distant from that and so
now there's a reconsideration of that
argument that argument seems to be
breaking out anew specifically over
Bolton who is a bush-era holdover and
Mike Pompeo who is not as much as a
Congress person before he headed on over
to the State Department okay we'll get
into more of this in just one second
first let's talk about knowing your
business inside and out so we run a
profitable business here at the Daily
wire right we're not a 501c3
we actually have to run a profit that
means we have to keep track of
everything that is going on in our
offices and most businesses do you want
to run a successful business you have to
make sure that you know your numbers if
you don't know your numbers you simply
don't know your business but the problem
growing businesses have is that they
have these hodgepodge business systems
so you don't actually have one
centralized place where you keep track
of all your numbers this is why you need
NetSuite by Oracle it's the business
management software that handles every
aspect of your business in an
easy-to-use cloud platform giving you
the visibility and control you need to
grow with NetSuite you save time money
and unneeded headaches by managing sales
finance and accounting orders and HR
instantly direct from your system your
debt see your desktop or your phone
that's why
sweet is the world's number one
cloud-based business system business
owners you need to know your business
the best way to do that is using that
suite right now
NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm slash Shapiro
that's NetSuite comm slash Shapiro to
download your free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits which I
think would be useful for everyone we
can all grow our profits NetSuite com
Shapiro go check them out right now use
that slash Shapiro so you get that
special deal on seven key strategies to
grow your profits alrighty we're gonna
get to more of John Bolten being fired
we'll also get to this North Carolina
special election Republicans did win in
North Carolina nine last night we'll
talk about that but first you have to go
over to daily wire and subscribe you
should do it I make a pitch every day 99
bucks a year it's getting near the end
of the year and I promise we are about
to implement all sorts of massive
changes over a daily wire like we're
flipping our website we have all sorts
of great new benefits for subscribers we
have some real goodies that are coming
up so go check us out right now ever
it's daily where 99 bucks a year for the
annual is better than $9.99 a month for
the monthly go check us out right now
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so the question about Bolton's Oscar is
whether it reflects deeper divides
inside the Trump administration about
foreign policy itself or whether this
was just interpersonal conflict and it's
not totally clear right see get Mike
Pompeo who is fairly hawkish on foreign
policy himself saying he disagreed with
Bolton many times he obviously looks
happy about this so maybe it was just an
interpersonal conflict can you describe
your working relationship with John
Bolton as it was because this departure
make it easier for you to do your job
and to the administration to accomplish
the president's foreign policy agenda
workings of how this all goes we we all
give our candid finish there were many
times ambassador Bolton I disagree
that's to be sure but that's true for
lots of lots of people who with whom I
interact
okay so Pompeo obviously had some
interpersonal problems and and people
like Lindsey Graham were close to the
administration also close to Bolton he
says it was probably coming because this
is as much a personality conflict as
anything else he says the president had
gotten into a situation where he didn't
like reading about some stuff in the
paper it got to be a breakdown of trust
that had pretty well shut down the
policy process among national security
agencies at the White House those
outside the inner sanctum were stunned
when Trump's tweet appeared at the
Pentagon there were cheers when Pompeo
appeared an unrelated new unrelated news
briefing shortly after Trump's tweet he
rebuff frantic questions about Bolton
saying he would not talk about the
administration's interworking Steve
minuchin also looked pretty pleased over
at the Treasury Department and he sort
of blamed this on the variant views of
Trump and Bolton on the Iraq war which
makes zero sense considering that the
United States does not have a lot going
on in Iraq at this point as compared
with Afghanistan one thing I would just
say follow-up exert pressure it's been
very clear on this the president's view
of the Iraq war and ambassador Bolton's
was very different the president's made
by favor okay so there is apparently a
long list of people inside the White
House who just didn't like Bolton very
much on a personal level apparently
including Melania Trump pence Mulvaney
Pompeo minuchin and other Defense
Department officials so maybe this was
all inter personal that's my hope is
that this was all inter personal I fear
that this is reflective of a move to the
left by the Trump administration on
foreign policy or at least a move toward
a more isolationist sentiment by the by
the Trump
administration so Tucker Carlson to take
an example was celebrating Bolton's
Easter last night you can see he's very
happy about all of this is Tucker and
Tucker suggested I think ridiculously
that Bolton is a man of the left which
is just bizarre and insane like there's
no evidence whatsoever that Bolton is a
left winger I mean really does the left
love John Bolton as I'm missing it if
you're wondering why so many
progressives are mourning Bolton's
firing tonight it's because Bolton
himself fundamentally was a man of the
left there was not a human problem John
Bolton wasn't totally convinced could be
solved with the brute force of
government that's an assumption of the
left not the right don't with the
mustache fool you John Bolton was one of
the most progressive people in the Trump
administration and by the way naturally
once he was descanse there Bolton
promoted Obama loyalists within the
National Security Council that shouldn't
surprise you either okay I don't know
what what this is referring to I mean
seriously the John Bolton is a man of
the left and the left was mourning him
yesterday
no the loves are just happy there was
chaos inside the Trump administration I
know anybody on the Left who was
thrilled about John bolt that means you
remember how upset they were when John
Bolton was hired then went nuts they
went nuts Rand Paul of course plays the
same tune he says that the threat of war
is diminished with Bolton gone let me
just make something clear here
hey this notion that John Bolton is
going around stumping for war if that
were the case wouldn't that have been a
little more war under John Bolton
because one of the things that I have
noticed is that John Bolton mainly
stymied President Trump for making a
crap deal with the North Koreans he was
apparently ready to sign an agreement
with the North Koreans in which the
United States would stop military
exercises would start to withdraw some
of its joint joint exercises with the
South Koreans would ease some of the
economic burden on North Korea in return
for empty promises and Bolton was like
no that's a bad idea
and then Bolton also undermined the
negotiations with Iran that were going
on that would have presumably returned
the United States to something
resembling the Iran nuclear deal from
which Trump litter in the first place
and then Bolton was standing strong
against this Taliban deal okay in none
of these cases was worthy the
alternative in none of these cases was
Bolton stumping for full-scale war with
any of these places okay so this is all
a buncha this is straw man crap here's
Rand Paul spewing it you know I think
the threat of war around the world is
rightly diminished with Bolton out of
the white house I think he had a naive
point of view for the world that we
should topple regimes everywhere and
Institute you know democratic
governments and we would make the world
perfect or remake the world in our image
and frankly just doesn't work that way
there's a lot of history of getting rid
of strongmen in the Middle East and
having them replaced by vacuums or chaos
or actually making the place more
hospitable for terrorist training yeah
again you can criticize Americans
interventionist foreign policy but doing
this whole thing about how America is
less likely to go to war now the john
bolton is out when there are two ways
America goes to war America goes to war
precipitously and America goes to war
reactively after 9/11 it was reactive
and then it became precipitous are you
more fearful that the Trump
administration is going to go to war
reactively or precipitously my fear is
that we will go to war reactively we
won't do enough we will be attacked and
then we'll be forced into a position of
doing something and so far that's been
Trump's tendency one of the things about
an active foreign policy is sometimes
you forestall war by preventing the
conditions that lead to an outbreak in
the first place the sort of pre-emptive
strategy of interventionism in foreign
policy those Bush in is that going to be
replaced by a different sort of
isolationist foreign policy now that
Bolton is out that remains to be seen
and I think that how we view 9/11 has
something to do with that I do I mean I
think that the relative unanimity that
we saw in the aftermath of 9/11 has
faded and now we are back to the Clinton
era arguments that took place frankly I
think we were back to those arguments as
soon as 2008 2009 when Barack Obama was
elected but to see that sort of cross
party lines is at the very least
somewhat disturbing I would prefer to
think and I think realistically that the
Trump administration is not going to
suddenly embrace all sorts of deals with
the world's worst regimes at least I
hope not instead I think that the Trump
administration will conflict that at
least is my hope I will say this when
Iran is celebrating the ouster of an
American advisor that's probably not a
great thing according to the Associated
Press Ron's president urged the United
States on Wednesday to quote put war
mongers aside as tensions royal the
Persian Gulf amid an escalating crisis
between Washington and Tehran in the
wake of collapsing nuclear deals with
world powers Hassan rouhani his remarks
signaled approval of
abrupt dismissal of John Bolton as a
national security adviser I have a
general rule anything the police's Iran
is bad hey the reason I say this is
because Iran is run by evil evil people
who have pursued awful violence in the
region against American allies against
against various sovereign countries you
know whenever whenever you are again
Iran celebrating is not a good thing for
the United States as a general rule okay
meanwhile over in North Carolina there
was a special election last night the
Democrats were hoping very much like
that Georgia district where John Asaf
ran and lost that they were gonna pull
out a surprise victory in a heavy red
district this victory this district was
won by President Trump in 2016 by 12
points well last night the district was
won again by a Republican it's been held
by Republican for something like 40
years it was won by two according to the
New York Times Dan Bishop a Republican
state senator scored a narrow victory on
Tuesday in a special house election in
North Carolina that demonstrated Trump's
appeal with his political base but also
highlighted his party's deepening
unpopularity with suburban voters bishop
defeated Dan McReady a moderate Democrat
one day after Trump made a full-throated
plea for support for the Republican at a
rally on the conservative end of a
Charlotte of Fayetteville district which
the president carried by nearly 12
points in 2016 with most votes counted
as of Tuesday night Bishop was ahead by
about two percentage points according to
the Associated Press the fierce fight
from the 9th congressional district also
brought to an end a tortured political
drama the 2018 midterm race for the seat
in which Macready barely lost against a
different Republican was in question for
months because of evidence of election
fraud on the GOP side that election was
thrown out in a special election had to
be held in a Democrat lost actually by
more votes than the Democrat lost the
first time around so the question is
what kind of bellwether this is
President Trump believes that this is a
bellwether for coming Republican victory
in 2020 and he tweeted out as much he
tweeted dan Bishop was down 17 points
three weeks ago he then asked me for
help we changed his strategy together
and he ran a great race big rally last
night now it looks like he is gonna win
CNN and MSNBC are moving their big
studio equipment and talent out stay
tuned
Trump is obviously correct that CNN and
MSNBC were in mourning last night it's
always amusing to watch as as president
Trump takes credit for victory and casts
blame
whenever there is a loss I really doubt
that a fish up lost you have been like
well you know went in there it didn't
help yeah what wasn't gonna go that way
but Trump is correct that his
last-minute push must have helped Bishop
I mean I was a slim close race Trump
gets out the base he's a formidable
political figure at getting out the base
as I am fond of saying winning an
election in the United States is about
two things making it unpalatable to vote
for your opponents and making it very
palatable for people to vote for you
Trump is fantastic at the former and he
is not phenomenal at the latter getting
people to vote for him however he does
drive out the base right there are a lot
of people who show up to vote against
him but in a special election where
turnout is going to be low Trump's
presents there may have been the turning
point for for the for the Republican in
this race Bishop now is it true that
Bishop was down 17 points a couple of
weeks ago I haven't seen any data that
supports that it was a pretty close race
for weeks and months but still Trump
helped I mean Trump showing up and
rallying helped and that's why I said
yesterday on the show that President
Trump's rally was a good moment for
Trump it looked a lot like what 2020 has
to look like him touting his economic
record and him pointing at Democrats and
suggesting that they are indeed
incredibly radical the Democrats are
only lost narrowly because they were
running a blue dog democrat in this race
they're running an ex-military member
who was fairly moderate on a lot of push
button policies and that guy only lost
by two now the possibility here is the
Democrats failed to take a lesson the
lesson Democrats should take is if we
run a very good candidate in a red
district it turns purple and if we run a
very good Democratic candidate in a
purple district it turns blue in other
words they should be running more toward
the center and not proclaiming
progressive policy as the be-all end-all
but it seems like they're taking the
opposite message which is I guess we
didn't get out our base enough so for
example you get this article from the
Washington Post
filip bump quote our moderate Democratic
candidates the safe bet they used to be
his impression is that what Democrats
really needs to do is skew to the
progressive left now if that's the last
thing you took out of NC nine you're
getting it wrong hey the only reason
that was a competitive race is because
Democrats ran a very good candidate in
that race against a somewhat weak
Republican candidate in eight
when Republicans are not overwhelmingly
popular but if Democrats had run AOC in
that district they lose by 30 right but
a lot of Democrats are taking the wrong
message so Phillip bump says since
Barack Obama was elected president in
2008 there's been a slow uptick in
Americans reporting's satisfaction with
how things are going in the country you
can see that in the Gallup polling over
the course of 2008 Gallup data indicated
that on average 15% of Americans were
satisfied with how things were going in
2009 that jump to an average of 26%
before slipping back into the upper
teens by 2011 by Obama's last year in
office the average was 27% but just
carried into 2017 president Trump's
first year in office in 2018 the figure
is over 30 percent so far this year the
average has fallen slightly now I love
that he's attributing this to politics
okay the fact is that this has nothing
to do with politics and everything to do
with how the economy is going in other
words when the economy sucks
satisfaction goes down and when the
economy gets better satisfaction goes up
but bum says during the 1990s views of
satisfaction among Democrats and
Republicans generally tracked with one
another starting in 2001 when George W
Bush became president temas Democratic
satisfaction tanked while Republicans
remain confident with how things were
going at least until push was reelected
then the Iraq war in the economy
submarine satisfaction even within
Bush's own party satisfaction stayed low
among Republicans during Obama's two
turns recovering only once Trump won
from victory though prompted Democrats
to suddenly see the direction of the
country as increasingly unsatisfactory
so there he's read about this there is a
partisan gap in satisfaction with the
country that is largely based on
political control but overall the
satisfaction with the country tends to
track with the economy fairly well
during Bill Clinton's presidency
Democrats and Republicans differed in
their satisfaction over how things were
going by about 19 points on average
under Bush that cap soared to an average
of 40 points under Trump the average gap
has been 45 points fellow bum says this
largely mirrors another metric which is
presidential job approval because of
partisanship so he says all of this
brings us to the question we're here to
answer does this new reality suggest new
mechanics will be in play in 2020 and on
Tuesday the New York Times looked at the
history of successful Democratic
moderates in political campaigns even in
the 2018 Democratic wave they argue more
moderate candidates had more success in
congressional campaigns that's good news
for the current leader former vice
president Joe
but they say do more moderate positions
mean that Biden has a better chance of
winning but says Philip bump Democrats
hate Trump so hatred of Trump may drive
them to support more progressive
policies and drive them out to the polls
so he suggests that it is possible more
a more progressive candidate will be
will be more useful to Democrats he says
the countervailing theory to a moderate
is the safer bet for Democrats is a
variant on the Ted Cruz theory of 2016
nominate a hard right conservative more
moderate Republicans will vote for that
candidate anyway but conservatives were
the ones staying home and now they'll
show up so the idea from Democrats is
very similar filip bum says most
democrats now identify as liberal that's
a shift that has been slowly happening
in the party with self-identified
liberals passing moderates during
Obama's tenure so the question comes
down to energy so Democrats may in fact
take the wrong lesson from nc9 and then
run somebody who is radically
progressive now again the reason that
this is not going it may be true on a
national popular vote level that you get
more people from New York and California
to vote for you if you run Elizabeth
Moore and then if you run Joe Biden but
Ohio Wisconsin Pennsylvania Michigan are
those the areas where you actually need
a more progressive candidate if
Democrats take their lesson I think that
will be a massive massive mistake so I
hope they make that mistake I hope they
continue along these lines in the end is
NC 9 an indicator that is good for
Republicans well no it's never great
when you drop from our plus twelve to
our plus two but does it spell complete
crisis in 2020 for Republicans the way
that a Republican loss may have no not
quite and it still shows that President
Trump has some last minute push button
appeal and with Republicans that many
Democrats are not like for example
there's a poll out of Texas today that
shows a bunch of Democrats ahead of
President Trump in Texas in the national
election but none of those Democrats is
breaking is breaking 50 every single
Democrat in that poll is stuck in the
upper 40s which really suggests that
President Trump is going to win that
state and probably win the state pretty
handily all of the polls that have Trump
down at 42 right now have no Democratic
opponent rights Trump against generic
Democrat well Trump against generic
Democrat probably gets 40 percent in
against Hillary Clinton Trump against
generic Democrat ends up with something
like 46 percent okay so the opponent
matters very very much here NC 9
demonstrates that but I think Democrats
may take the wrong lesson at least I
hope so
alright time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like today so I'm constantly
hearing questions from parents about
what are some great books for kids I
love this series from Brad Meltzer
illustrated by Christopher iliopoulos
it's called the I M series the ordinary
people change the world series and it's
great they have these books about Albert
Einstein have recommended them before
there are two new ones that have just
come out one is called I am Walt Disney
and the other is I am Mary Curie and
it's just leave these are great books
they're all about the obstacles that
these historical figures had to overcome
and the great things that they did I
just read my daughter the one on Marie
Curie and first of all taught me things
that I didn't remember about Mary Kerry
and second of all it really is inspiring
for kids my daughter turned to me and
she said when I grow up I want to be a
scientist I said well you know mommy's
also a scientist mommy's a doctor said
no I want to be a real scientist she
wants to be a research scientist which
is just awesome and she is super smart
and so she will probably make that
happen she's a very determined kid and
these books are just great they're
really pro-america but in these sort of
non flag-waving sense meaning that the
ones about American citizens they don't
sugarcoat American history they've won
about Jackie Robinson the talks about
racism in American history but reminds
you that america is the land of
opportunity and reminds you that the
most successful people in life are the
people who work through obstacles and
and work hard and take advantage of the
opportunities that they have and make
opportunities for themselves I love this
series I really do and I recommend it
for all kids it's the the ordinary
people change the world series from Brad
Meltzer the new ones that are outer I am
Walt Disney and I'm Mary Kerry they're
just fantastic you should go check them
out right now okay time for a couple of
quick things that I hate
California sucks
they just gonna put that out there so
I've lived here my entire life except
for three years when I was in Cambridge
Massachusetts California is terrible and
they continue to push terrible policy
the Democrats in Sacramento today
California legislators approved a
landmark bill on Tuesday that requires
companies like uber and lyft to treat
contract workers as employees a move
that could reshape the gig economy and
that adds fuel to a year's long debate
over whether the nature of work has
become too insecure this is the part
where we remind everybody that if you
make all of these people employees then
uber and lyft have to pay them like
employees and not like independent
contractors which means that the price
dramatically goes up on consumers which
means fewer people are employed okay
that's what's going to happen here
you're artificially boosting wages as
opposed to just paying people what they
want to take a job for the uber and lyft
have transformed the transportation
economy particularly in the city of Los
Angeles which is very spread out you've
seen this in New York where people with
taxi medallions have been lobbying for
years to have a bura and lyft treated as
though all of the drivers are actually
working directly for the business
creating liability and health insurance
issues and all of the rest of it well I
don't blame the the folks who paid 50
grand for a taxi medallion in New York
because New York had created this
idiotic cartel in Los Angeles you want
to make LA a lot worse place to live do
exactly this and then of course is what
they're doing we have a massive homeless
problem here in Los Angeles a lot of
people who are seeking jobs to tide them
over from job to job drive over and left
I mean if ever driven with any of these
rideshare services and you talk to the
folks who are driving very often they'll
say yeah I'm between jobs right now and
one of the ways I'm paying my rent is
that I was able to become one of these
drivers I'm like 48 hours notice and
it's allowing me to pay my bills so
California's gonna take that ability
away from you which is just spectacular
the bill passed in a twenty nine to
eleven vote in the state Senate and will
apply to app based companies despite
their efforts to negotiate an exemption
Gavin Newsom who has the looks and
brains of a Ken doll endorsed at the
bill this month and is expected to sign
it after it goes through the state
assembly under the measure workers must
be designated as employees instead of
contractors if a company exerts control
over how they perform their tasks or if
their work is part of a company's
regular business which of course is
idiotic I use FedEx all the time and I
direct them how
do their work where'd you take my
packages does that mean that FedEx is
now my employee or are they my agent the
bill may influence other states a
coalition of labor groups of course is
pushing similar legislation in New York
because they don't like free and open
competition in the labor market instead
they prefer unionized work that raises
wages but limits employment meanwhile
Gavin Newsom signed another idiotic bill
today this bill prevents schools from
suspending disruptive students from
kindergarten through eighth grade
because nothing makes education in
California's public schools better than
having a kid who's being a little crap
disrupting the class and not being able
to do anything about it Gavin Newsom
signed the law Senate bill 419 it
permanently prohibits willful defiance
suspensions in grades four and five it
also bans such suspensions in grades six
through eight for five years nothing
like taking away a tool that a teacher
has to remove a bad influence from a
classroom nothing ruins a classroom
quite like disruptive children they
can't do anything about in fact I
remember even when I was in private
school you'd get this because if the
parents were big donors to the school
then teachers were reluctant to remove
the kids from the classroom those were
always the kids who were in the
classroom now the reason they're doing
this is because they suggest that too
many minority kids are being suspended
from class okay well first of all there
are a lot of minority teachers who are
suspending minority kids this is not
necessarily the result of some endemic
racism maybe kids who are acting badly
should stop acting badly in class and
their parents should step in there is
this endemic problem white black and
green in the United States and that is
the parents these days toss their kids
on schools and then expect the teachers
to raise their kids for them and then if
their kids come home and they're like ah
my teacher got on my case the parents
call up the teacher and whine about it
and you know what happens if a teacher
calls us up and say is your kid is
making trouble in class the talk that I
have is not with the teacher the talk I
have is with my kid because my
assumption is that adults more know that
adults know more than children you know
why because kids are dumb kids don't
know things kids don't have behavioral
regulation their brains aren't that
developed yet you need to be able to
remove disruptive students from the
classroom because especially in LA you
got like 30 other kids in the classroom
I've been in classrooms where kids are
disruptive I'm sure you have too it is
not a pretty picture and it tends to
have a snowball effect because once kids
know they can get away with something
then all the kids start acting this way
the bill was opposed by the charter
school development center whose
executive director argued that this was
one-size-fits-all legislation that is a
fix in search of a problem when that is
correct but they there is this this
whole case that this is one of the best
ways to disrupt the school to Prison
Pipeline right I'm sure that suspending
kids from class is what causes them to
be bad kids not the fact that they were
being bad kids in class which is why
they were suspended in the first place
I would love to see the control group
here the kids who were terrible in class
were not suspended and then ended up
being fortune 500 CEOs as opposed to
kids were suspended their parents called
the school that parents punished the kid
and then the kid got back on the
straight and narrow alrighty we'll be
back here later today for two additional
hours of content and as always you know
I I think we should keep 911 in our
hearts and minds today remember what
that was like and remember that that
sort of thing can happen again if the
United States falls asleep again you're
listening to the Ben Shapiro show
you
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo wide outski
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright day Lee Weyer
2019 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show you know
some people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]